[Música]
en france 24 seguimos informando las
últimas noticias relacionadas a la
invasión rusa en ucrania donde la
población civil sufre todos los días las
consecuencias de esta guerra en nuestro
programa directo américa conversamos con
varias de las personas en el terreno
para conocer así los distintos puntos de
vista y las historias de primera mano
hoy la comunidad internacional como
también lo estábamos comentando con rosa
pérez y con nuestro informativo se
despertó con tristeza y rechazó de
manera categórica el ataque al teatro de
mariupol donde según la información
preliminar dada a conocer por un
diputado hasta el momento no se reportan
víctimas ya que las personas se
encontraban en un refugio antiaéreo que
sigue recibiendo ataques mientras que el
beef es una de las ciudades donde aún es
relativamente seguro estar es donde se
encuentran varios periodistas
internacionales reportando la situación
como solo macaluso ellas el periodista
que se encuentra en el terreno
seguramente también la pueden conocer
por sus redes sociales en un caso que
vamos a comentar con ella solo gracias
por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de france 24 para mí es un gusto
estar contigo esta mañana me pregunto
cómo ha vivido la guerra en ucrania como
tanto tiempo en un país invadido
hoy
para pasar conectando a ustedes muchas
gracias por la invitación en cuanto a tu
pregunta en lo personal y cada día un
nuevo desafío y un nuevo aprendizaje es
mi primera cobertura de guerra hemos
pasado por diferentes ciudades en estos
casi dos meses de cobertura y sin dudas
como digo un nuevo desafío diario como
lo enfrentas te dices que es tu primera
en cobertura de guerra tuviste un poco
de miedo como ha hecho también para todo
este tiempo para decir como formándote
formará a lo mejor esa coraza que uno
como periodista tiene que tener para
cubrir estas situaciones de desgracia
humana sol
bueno yo creo que ee
en 2
de esta cobertura si alguien no tuviera
miedo sería un indicativo de que no
podría estar aquí es pensar es distinto
también desperté para gobernar este tipo
y en cuanto a lo de la coraza creo que
es mi trabajo
no más
para ti
justamente eso que además los
profesionales somos humanos y tenemos
que comunicar con emoción sobre todo
cada persona que conocemos cada persona
local es una historia en sí misma y se
trata justamente de eso para lo que más
allá de los números que podemos
comunicar todo si ha habido siete diez o
veinte ataques con misiles rusos que
entiendan lo que le está sucediendo a la
gente
precisamente eso le quería preguntar
preguntar sólo cuál es la situación de
estas personas ustedes ha podido ha
tenido la oportunidad de estar con ellos
de compartir con ellos pues que sienten
bueno una angustia terrible porque
además compañero la verdad que desde
enero que llevamos haciendo la cobertura
en este país he hecho miles de
entrevistas nadie imaginaba que esto
pudiera pasar cada vez que preguntábamos
si veía en un ataque a gran escala por
parte de vladimir putin aquí en el país
nos decían que no hoy que si pasaba algo
se cree que se quedaría centrado en la
zona de el donbass en nadie imagina
que ese ataque pudiera llegar a quien y
mucho menos a toda la ciudad de c's
también que están siendo asediadas
nosotros realizamos una cobertura
bastante extensa en el yankee de la
ciudad ucrania más fronteriza con rusa
que ahora están siendo fuertemente
bombardeada también y la gente por
supuesto mucha angustia son más de 33
millones los que han abandonado el país
pero también muchos otros que continúan
en el mismo parada para defenderlo hay
un vídeo que se hizo virar en las redes
sociales donde explicaba la situación de
un señor que le pedía que se hiciera
cargo de su hija qué pasó en ese momento
cuál es la situación de los niños no en
un conflicto
bueno creo que los niños por supuesto
como en toda situación son los más
vulnerables y los más inocentes
es este señor es productos locales con
quien llevo desde enero después de
tantos días de cobertura uno se
convierte en familia entonces me pidió
el favor
de que me lleve a su hija a españa país
en el cual estoy viviendo y no lo dudé
ni un segundo creo que cualquier ser
humano hubiese tenido mi misma respuesta
solamente que no pensé por su puesto
yo en
mi decisión era abandonar ucrania y
regresar a españa con su hija primera
asignatura por eso seguimos aquí
informándoles de terreno y a su hija se
le hacemos que su hija tiene 17 años que
ha sido una compañera de maestra del
equipo se encuentran muy bien ya salvo
en español
entonces se encuentra digamos en españa
en un terreno seguro solo la verdad que
pues yo creo que sí también una persona
de buen corazón pues haría una labor o
como esa que pues tampoco es fácil
digamos hacerse cargo del hijo de otra
persona también poco se habla de las
familias de personas que como usted
están trabajando en el terreno que dice
la familia al respecto que dicen las
personas o tus seres queridos sus
allegados digamos personalizamos la
historia pero como tú hay miles de
periodistas de miles de personas que
están haciendo información labores
humanitarias o sea cuál es la situación
realmente de las familias de los que
están detrás de la cámara
bueno supongo por supuesto que cada
situación será particular porque cada
familia cada persona es un mundo aparte
en lo que a mí respecta por supuesto
están súper preocupados y si fuera por
ellos quisiera que esté en casa desde
hace ya semanas pero al mismo tiempo me
apoyan y respetan la decisión se
quedaron aquí informando pero eso no
quita que la preocupación me esté
constantemente yo me encargo de hablar
mucho con ellos de llevarles calma pero
obviamente supongo que cualquier padre
estaría preocupado al tener a su hijo
también reiteró siendo mi primera
cobertura de rne no tenía experiencia
previa eso también incluye no solamente
en mi trabajo sino también en la
preocupación de mi familia pero confían
en mí y sobre todo me apoyan y tratan de
entender muy rápidamente solo en vez de
segunditos que nos quedan antes de
terminar nuestra conversación que
medidas de protección tienen usted en el
terreno
cascos y chalecos antibalas que en caso
de alarmas de sirenas por ejemplo aquí
leo pólizas tendríamos que utilizar y
siempre tenerlos a mano porque cualquier
cosa que pudiera suceder por supuesto
puesto el gracias por su tiempo por
estar con nosotros en este espacio de
france 24 directo américa ha sido un
gusto para mí haber conversado con usted
cuídese mucho y bueno es gran trabajo
que está realizando en esta su primera
cobertura en un conflicto
muchísimas gracias a una hora sobra